joining us tonight is Curtis Curtis
white to read and discuss the middle
mind his new book originally an essay in
Harper's this book is a quote remarkably
original and entertaining examination of
the current failure of the American
imagination in the media politics
education art technology and religion
this book discusses why we should and
how we can regain a bit of our lost
originality mr. white is the author of
two novels memories of my father
watching TV and Requiem his work appears
regularly in context and Harper's please
join me in welcoming Curtis white thanks
very much
can you hear me all right out there no
it should either be louder or I should
be closer or something should happen I
can't do this like this for life sorry
that won't work
can you hear me now maybe all the
pressure jeez
okay you know we're on TV we can't be
fooling around here too long okay
the this book is not really exclusively
about this thing called the middle mind
the middle mind is in MIDI many ways a
sort of a peg to hang a hat on it's a
narrative hook it's it's if you will or
if you insist the buzz as they talk now
among the chattering classes which I've
never heard of either before this book
came out it was the the original buzz
but the book in a larger senses is about
the imagination and I usually talk about
the imagination in this book in terms of
what I call the social imagination and I
define it for the purposes of the
argument I'm making as having two
capacities the imagination the social
imagination has must possess the
capacity for critiquing what exists one
and two projecting something other than
what exists into the future as a kind of
possibility as a promise for the human
world so having said that I I have to
comment that it's it's very nice for me
to be here in Berkeley because when I
was a kid growing up in the East Bay and
what they call a vet village Levittown
West San Lorenzo about 40 miles down the
road I one of my first experiences of
what I considered to be the imagination
to pot the possibility for a future that
was something other than the world as it
presented to itself to me down in the
suburbs was here in Berkeley and in San
Francisco later when I went to school
there but when I when I was in high
school my friends and I would pile into
I think it was a 54 Chevy and had to
plow our way up the warm down the up the
warren freeway into Berkeley and
suddenly spill into this world that just
seems so completely other than the than
the world that we were inhabiting down
in San Lorenzo and you know they just it
presented itself to us yeah it made a
kind of proposal about the world that
was just completely inescapable for us I
mean it was something that we had to
take seriously even though when we came
here mostly what we came to do was was
to find out what music the hippies were
listening to now which was of course
always interesting to us or to shop at
the old Vaughn's men store Vaughn's at
site say the gate right so so that that
makes it very nice indeed for me to be
here again sort of I feel like I'm sort
of repaying some sort of debt coming
back here to talk about the imagination
I a little bit about the history about
how this book came to be it was about
three summers ago and I was you know in
my usual perusing of the culture
becoming increasingly irritated with
certain things I think I found myself
caught in the car with Terry Gross as
fresh air one too too many times that
particular summer and you know is sort
of one of those right early irritations
where you know eventually you've got to
do something with with it and also the
movie Saving Private Ryan by Steven
Spielberg and a couple of other books
that were pretending to to be serious
books while I thought really failing to
do that and so I ended up asking myself
a question that would went something
like are these books merely all
individually hopelessly mediocre or can
they be said to be part of what we might
call an American mind and I decided
whether you could call it a part of
American an American mind or not it
would be interesting to pretend that it
was one way or the other that's sort of
how the the fiction writer and me
operates anyway so I fictionally
proposed to myself that there was the
thing called the middle mind and then I
I said about writing the essay simply as
a way of discovering what the heck it
might be
thus we novelists work and it's very
interesting for me also I have to
confess being essentially a novelist and
then being told this that I'm a social
critic yeah because I have I wanted to
do three things with this book I wanted
to write a book that was beautiful just
as I in the way that I would try to
write a beautiful novel I wanted the
second thing I wanted to do is I wanted
to misbehave in the most serious and
dangerous way that I could find and that
meant essentially talking about things
that I had no business talking about and
I think I do that at all on almost every
single page you'll find I'm talking
about things that have no business
talking about and some of the reviews
that have have appeared about the book
talk about how it meticulously its
research which always makes me laugh
because I promise you there's nothing
meticulous about this book my my guiding
purpose in writing this book was was
pure purely Joycean and Joyce always
always said you know I mean there's a
lot of research in Joyce so to speak but
his guiding principle had nothing to do
with expertise or thoroughness it had to
do with trusting that what you needed
would come to you and so as I wrote this
book and started opening up new areas in
which I could talk about things I had no
business talking about I always trusted
what I needed would come to me so when
I'm told that the book is meticulously
researched I it seems to me very funny
the third thing that I wanted to do in
the book was I wanted to win which is to
say I wanted the book to be persuasive
and I think that that that third part
kind of wraps back around and catches on
to the first part which is to make it I
wanted to write a beautiful book so part
of what being persuasive or winning for
me means having created a voice that is
that is a compelling voice another and
creating a vision and an imagined way of
thinking the world that is that is
persuasive that is powerful that is
compelling and my model in this
oddly enough was and you know I I think
that there are a lot of lacks in Michael
Moore's work I and but the one thing I
have to say that I think is quite
brilliant about Michael Moore is that he
understands that that winning is not
necessarily about knowing something that
other people don't know and the most
brilliant thing that Michael Moore did
does with his work whether it's in the
movies of the books is that he invented
this character called Michael Moore and
it's really in some ways the the
cultural politics of Michael Moore's
work goes in the fight it works sort of
in this way he's sort of saying who
would you rather hang out with me or
rush you know and that you know he kind
of brings people over to his team and
cultural politics I think have always
worked in that way I mean I mean I think
that for example as we all know the The
Beatles and John Lennon in particular
were tremendously influential cultural
and political figures but it wasn't
because gentleman and knew anything
about politics and when you know when he
started having the kind of effect that
he we all know he had and people asked
him what his politics were he was
usually pretty incoherent but what was
really powerful about Lennon was simply
his lemonis you know his presence and he
was persuasive at a purely aesthetic or
stylistic level and it was more it was a
you know who do you want to hang out at
that time was with at that time wasn't
matter of you want to hang out with
Lennon who do you want to hang out with
with Kissinger or somebody know so was
it was an easy choice well it's pretty
easy choice now if it's between my
crewmate between Moore and Rush Limbaugh
but so to go back to my brief history of
how this book came to be I published the
essay in a journal called context first
and then it was picked up by Harper's
Magazine and and and put in its reading
section and one of the astonishing
things that happened once it appeared in
Harper's is that I never asked if I set
a record for hate mail but I think I may
have just sort of judging by the
thickness of the pack of letters that
they sent me which I was called really
quite an astonishing number of names
mostly by a people who were were
offended because I had the temerity to
attack one of America's sacred cows
although I didn't know she was a sacred
cow at the time and they might have
considered what I was doing differently
if I had Terry gross so Terry's fans
really rushed to the rush to the front
but it was good clean fun for me
subsequently an editor at Harpers San
Fransico read the essay in Harper's and
contacted me and he you know he asked
would you like to do a book version of
the middle mind to which I said no I
mean there's no way that I want to
become known as the guy who invented the
middle mind and I certainly don't want
to try to find a book length series of
examples like Terry Gross that seems a
real waste of my time but I would be
interested in doing a book about
aesthetics and politics and I thought I
said that's way too academic sounding
for any commercial publisher and I've
heard the last of him but much to my
surprise he did come back and we sort of
negotiated an idea and when we finally
came to a place where you know we could
agree that we were both excited about it
I kind of went from there and thus
that's the book so my argument in the
book has is basically that this thing
the social imagination is impoverished
in the present it's not that it doesn't
exist but that it exists in an
impoverished way in the present and in
some ways I do think that the story I'm
telling has a lot to do with the
apparently endless reaction against the
60s you know that goes back to the Big
Chill and what was happening in the late
70s and I think what the powers-that-be
whatever you want to call him the power
elite the ruling order whatever
discovered in the 60s was that the
imagination as as this capacity within
us that's quite
popular to propose alternative futures
is potentially powerful it's
destabilizing and it's very inefficient
it's not once its out and I talk about
it as being at-large in a way that a
madman or a criminal might be at large
once it is at large it's very difficult
to control to know where the heck is
going to go so the I've organized the
book in a series of chapters that have
to do with what I call the the enemies
of the imagination and I kind of I
suppose and dramatized the the situation
in sort of like George Bush you know
George Bush has his axis of evil and
evildoers in dark dens that he's gonna
smoke out etc so you know I thought I
would take a page from his book and I
would create these enemies of the
imagination the the enemies here for me
are the the the middle mind who's who's
whose world is properly speaking the
world of media and entertainment what I
call academic orthodoxy and finally
political ideology and a big part of
political ideology that that discussion
for me comes to be about the
technological imagination and these
these three institutional enemies of the
imagination their function is to manage
essentially and they they don't deny
they don't forbid the imagination that's
not not something that is possible and
probably certainly not efficient but
what they can do is manage and limit the
scope they can limit the power of the
imagination and I think that they do
that have you know if you think back to
the way that just the arts the social
imagination is not constituted by the
arts but if you think back to the
situation that we had in the late 60s
what the arts were doing at that time
they were they were a lot more out they
were a lot freer they were a lot more
public whether you're talking about
cinema theatre the novel poetry the
visual arts pop art etc they were much
more a public part of our lives
presently I think that the situation and
the only exception to this I think might
you might say would be rock and roll
which continues to come you know at
least start from basements and garages
but the situation since the late sixties
has become very much more that those art
forms have been institutionalized and
has come to a point now where you know
for example poets basically are only
read by other poets usually with some
sort of connection with with
universities and I know that situation
might be a little different here in
Sderot Berkeley but nationally I think
that that's a pretty accurate
description my friend Andre Codrescu
likes to ask sort of rhetorically you
know what ever happened to all those
guys that we're carrying around Gregory
Corso and you Lawrence Ferlinghetti and
you'd get on a bus and there'd be at
least three or four people with with a
volume of poetry on the bus what
happened to those guys so in some ways
I'm trying to answer that question in
this book so the answer to the to the
question that the cover asks why why
don't Americans think for themselves you
know I've been on so many radio programs
and it seems in the last month or so and
it seems as if everybody's assumption is
that I think that people are stupid
they're lazy they're stupid there's some
personal flaw and I really resist that
and I and it really never occurred to me
that that would be anything like an
answer because it seems stupid to
project a personal flaw upon the the you
know the public body and the answer to
the question why don't Americans think
for themselves is for me that we're very
well managed at this point and so the
real problem for us is how to defeat
that management and reclaim the social
imagination so I thought at this point I
would read a little bit from the book if
you'll tolerate that and then we'll do
some questions and answers I like to
read from the beginning of the book
because I think I'm most charming there
the book is I'm not always charming in
the book in fact some a lot of people
have commented that is it is a very
aggressive and polemical book and that I
attack people you know that I shouldn't
be attacking people that other people
are fond of after all and why am i
upsetting their notions of the worth of
Terry Gross etc in fact um the book is
going to come out in England in the
spring and this logic if I can pronounce
his name wrote this really wonderful
blurb for it and he he refers to what I
do in the book as malevolent irony he
says it's wonderful I think it's gonna
sell a lot in England he says I'm a
level and irony emerges from every page
of the book and I said well finally
someone noticed you know I tried to put
a lot of malevolent irony into this book
and no one said a darn thing about it so
at least Dziedzic did and now I suppose
everyone in England will be looking for
it you tell me if you see any malevolent
irony and what I'm gonna read but most
of mostly this part here is very
charming and I figured that's a good
marketing tool being charming he didn't
seem like he was malevolent he seemed
charming ed Henry from the introduction
it begins with an epigraph from Hugh
Kenner and it says this is from the the
book the pound era
whoever can give his people better
stories than the ones they live in is
lie to the priest in whose hands common
bread and wine become capable of feeding
the very soul
one afternoon about 15 years ago the
artist Nicholas africana and I were
visiting a common friend bill Morgan who
was recovering from surgery in a
hospital here in Normal Illinois we sat
there talking in an awkward no we're
unsure of whether or not the simple
facts of the situation were available
for conversation all I wanted was for
the moment to be familiar I wanted to be
able to gossip and indulge in my
habitually heightened sense of irony but
a different sort of reality was
asserting itself pain uncertainty
physical disfigurement maybe even good
old mr. death so the scene was made by
the discomfort of friends who had no
access to their ordinary report and who
were afraid to talk about what was right
in front of them or at least that's how
I felt my options were crusty with as
Wallace Stevens might have put it the
quotidian what you're supposed to do our
friend bill was of course often some
sweet land of morphine indifference but
Nicholas to my amazement was somewhere I
could never have anticipated apropos of
nothing he said pointing to a length of
clear plastic tubing suspended above us
that amber light is beautiful and there
in fact was a tiny amber light in the
middle of the tubing a little light I
hadn't noticed at all it was bright like
an isolated star it triangulated us
suddenly the situation changed for me
into something completely other than it
had been the moment before we'd been
translated reordered Nicholas's comment
reconstituted us I had a powerful
feeling that everything had just been
changed utterly and made what other word
was there for it beautiful I smiled
suddenly happy I looked at Nicholas in
awe and I thought you can do that the
tiny amber light perched angelically
above us functioned like wallace stevens
'as jar
on a hill in Tennessee and quote from
the poem I placed a jar in Tennessee and
round it was upon a hill
it made the slovenly wilderness surround
that hill the other Tennessee the real
Tennessee is annihilated by Stephens jar
just as the quotidian world of hospitals
and sick friends was destroyed by
Nicholas's observation his gesture
seizing on that which otherwise passes
notice is a metaphor for the world
making capacities of the imagination my
experience I think says something about
the fact that the imagination is not
only about creation it is also about how
we see and how we experience we cannot
create in a fresh and lively way while
looking at our world from a stale even a
familiar and comforting perspective so
before the productive work of the
imagination can begin we must be outside
of the familiar africanus subtle gesture
D familiarized in a moment in an instant
pop he created a gap in which the
imagination could do its work the scene
deployed itself differently offering
itself openly to the imagination if I
felt a little like laughing in that
moment it was because i intuited the
opportunity and wondered what bill or
his doctor would make of this
opportunity
of course the quotidian version of
things in which I had been slumbering
was also an act of the imagination just
as Knoxville Tennessee is an act of the
imagination to which we dedicate
ourselves daily out of a mix of
necessity joy fear and habit but mine
was an act of the imagination that I
would describe as crusted over just as
Knoxville is a city crusted over and
whatever town you're sitting in right
now even dear old Berkeley be it large
or small is crusted over and much in
need of someone like Africana to point
over your head just outside of your
peripheral vision where there is a
little amber light that you've never
noticed
that wants very much to show you
something you could not suspect without
it so my intention in this book is to
explore the poverty of the imagination
through the media academia and politics
the three areas of public life that
provide the vehicles for the great
antagonists of the imagination
entertainment orthodoxy and ideology but
I also want to think more positively
about the present condition of our
religious and civic spirit as well as
about something that I will call the
sublime that which beckons to us beyond
the suffocating of familiar activities
of of those three enemies the sublime is
that indistinct but essential thing that
Wallace Stevens called the necessary
angel it has something very simple
if curiously distant to say to us it
wants to tell us that change is real and
the world can be other than it is think
of the next four sections of Violation
read that because I'm not going to read
all four sections back in his glory days
with the Talking Heads David Byrne wrote
a song called found a job the scene he
described concerned a family that is
bored with TV and decides it will make
its own TV shows I'm tempted to sing
this but I'll resist judy's in the
bedroom inventing situations if you know
this song you know you can do consume
Bob is on the street today scouting up
locations they've enlisted all their
family they've enlisted all their
friends the song concludes if your work
isn't what you love then something isn't
right
Byrne describes a tension that is
fundamental and inescapable between
capitalism and the populations it
organizes our culture provides
entertainment as a compensation for and
an end an inducement to work it
reconciles work and leisure and
reconciles production and consumption it
eliminates contradictions that would
otherwise be intolerable and then an
imagined voice suddenly pops in
Quotes this is what I get get from my
lost years in the corporate Carol Fox
programming reality TV maybe this is the
malevolent irony part hot babes and
halter tops eating insects cops I might
as well get a billy club and beat myself
up I think I'd feel better about it all
when we recognize that entertainment is
boring and dishonest and the daily work
is unfulfilled resentment begins to grow
what we feel is disdain for what has
been provided for us especially in light
of what we might produce if our own
creativity were free in contrast with
the needs of capitalism creativity the
work of the imagination is a messy parot
plurality of human possibilities not
conducive to economic efficiency and so
capitalism has always had to find ways
to orient this messy plurality to the
business at hand work as capitalism's
great friend Walt Disney put it it's off
to work we go happily
whistling full of a sense of virtue with
pickaxes no less in the 20th and 21st
centuries this control has had less to
do with the raw repressive physical
obligation to work although that is not
absent and is certainly not absent in
Asian sweat sweat shops and the
maquiladoras of Mexico Mort it has had
more to do with managing our creativity
we American workers are more beguiled
than we are oppressed and the present
capitalism cannot entirely deny
creativity without risking another 60s
style flight from business as usual
capitalism will always be vulnerable to
the fact that people can refuse its
world as many did under Timothy Leary's
call to drop out on the one hand Leary
seemed a silly druggie fraud and no real
threat to anyone but he said something
terrifyingly simple and direct that was
echoed throughout the culture you don't
have to live this way
do something else at that time Leary was
simply the most recent incarnation of
the spirit of refusal Paul Goodman's
growing up absurd and Herbert Marcus's
one-dimensional man preceded him
this spirit of refusal was and is driven
by the question as Goodman put it of
what it means quote to grow up into such
a fact as during my productive years I
will spend eight hours a day doing what
is no good since the Reagan Revolution
Leary's call has not been broadly taken
up although the occasional indie rock
band like Talking Heads films like
Richard Linklater slacker and the punk
and slackers or subcultures have kept
the idea of refusal of capitalism's
world alive but my point is that the
tension between the imperative to work
and the human need to be free to create
one's own world is fundamental and
finally inescapable the imagination is
real and its defining concept is freedom
without freedom it cannot do its work
and so cannot be itself no amount of end
of history and of irony new world order
we beat the commies self-congratulation
will alter this fact there will always
be people especially young people who
will understand that getting a job is an
assault on what their intuition tells
them it means to be alive they'll always
just a little or maybe a lot resent it
that job and that resentment will always
be a threat to capitalism's order not
for nothing with the following words
attached to the entrance of the Sorbonne
in May of 1968 quote we are eventing
inventing a new and original world
imagination is seizing power
Sasa
questions comments was it malevolent
charmingly malevolent no with what the
middle minded Sophie okay the question
is the do I mean to say that we don't
need to know what the middle mind is
because I haven't told you yet what it
is okay
and that probably means that you'd like
me to tell you what it is okay
the the middle mind as a concept it the
reason I call that the middle mind is
because if we can understand the culture
wars of the of the 80s and 90s as
something that was taking place between
cultural traditionalists like William
Bennett and so-called tenured radicals
like Michael Berube or Roth or Andrew
Ross rather it seemed to me that those
two that those two groups were kind of
missing the point that there was another
combatant in in the and in on the field
and that it was really doing a better
job of sort of claiming this high ground
of you know what would pass for
seriousness in the culture and so and
and I caught and that's what I called
the middle mind was this middle player
so in this culture it seems to me the
things like Terry Gross is fresh air
passes for a kind of programming that is
serious in a way that commercial
programming is not or National Public
Radio or the things we see on public TV
passed for serious in a way that things
on commercial TV do not so we kind of
creates an opposition between the
commercial and the public that finally
to me was a false opposition because it
seems to me that what programs like
fresh air are finally doing is is not
providing a serious sort of intellectual
artistic you know grappling with issues
what they're finally in the business of
is marketing and the the thing in
particular that I look at is what I call
the death of discrimination
the words she the program I won't say
she cuz I don't want to pick on poor
Terri manat create a distinction between
say Barry Manilow and Christoph
Eschenbach and as a result of that
everything is good it's all good the
question then becomes what's it all good
for the answer to the question what's it
all good for is it's good to sell it's a
commodity it's a product I was reading
an interview with Andres Schifrin of the
new Press & Z magazine I think was in
the last issue and he and he was talking
about what he says all book publishers
know which is that there are two primary
ways to market to really critical and
primary ways to market a book in this
culture one is if you can get on Oprah
and the other is fresh air which was
surprising to me frankly but I believed
it and it kind of confirmed to my
suspicion you know of the real function
of the program so the middle mind for me
are those things that that pass for
serious as a way of kind of creating
something that's not commercial but are
in fact more like that commercial word
world than maybe they know themselves
but they're kind of fraud and you know
if you will what I've been thinking to
myself is that what I'm doing when I
take those opposition's between the
commercial and the serious that the
culture creates for us I've been calling
that a kind of popular deconstruction
because we have this opposition between
you know say what dan Rather does and
what all things considered does and we
say wow there's a you know a real
difference there and what I try to show
is that there's not a real difference
there and a lot of the book is is you
know it's this is not a book that beats
up on conservative culture you know
Michael Moore can do that or Bill Maher
can do that or Franken can do that this
book is really more looking at the ways
in which liberal culture fails us yes
I really enjoyed your book variant
immensely but I have one and one thing
stuck out to me and also in the folks
that you read today is it are you saying
it seems that does imaginative culture
have to come out of the garage if and it
seems that there are more paths to the
imagination even if not through comic if
they are not on the capitalist math then
you seem to refer to in your books
especially in reference to the idea of
rock and roll on the punks lack of
culture because there's a lot more
variations or versions of that than just
rock and roll Radiohead great but
there's a lot more version spin than
that well you know I live in Normal
Illinois so you talk about slack you
gotta cut me some slack you know I'm
sitting there in my living room in
Normal Illinois trying to write this
book you know it's not all marching by
my door so I attire I will go and if
you'd like we can go into the cruelties
of fate you know that that landed me in
Normal Illinois but I'm more than happy
to acknowledge that you know that there
are lots of places out there that I
don't talk about in the book that are
very useful high potential kind of
places for for launching you know works
of the imagination political acts of the
imagination what you will and so you
know I'm all I'm all for those things
you know and I'm happy to hear about
them in fact one of the things that I've
been most gratified by with this book is
the number of emails and letters and
presents you know that I've gotten from
people who've read the book and if you
have a present to send me please do I
mean I would like that but you know
recently a guy in Donald curry in San
Francisco sent me some CDs that he'd
produced there theater CDs and he has
this little company that he calls sex
and mayhem which is or maybe it's mayhem
in sex it's one of those two I think
it's sex and mayhem but they're
brilliant little theater pieces that
he's put together on these
on these CDs and you know I was just you
know I was not just flattered that he
sent me that but I was kind of inspired
to see that he was out there doing that
kind of work so yeah it's out there you
know the real problem for us isn't you
know there may be as much sort of art
scene activity and energy out there as
there's ever been what's really missing
right now is social penetration and that
is the Panda there you know we run into
a very familiar kind of problem in a
very familiar kind of enemy who knows
why the why the sort of 60s energy
energy penetrated so deeply within to
the culture and who knows really why it
all went away I mean we all have our
theories I suspect but our problem is is
is not only revivifying the imagination
but also again finding ways for it to
penetrate deeply into into the culture
yes sir resonated with the selling of
fear suppose the average citizen is not
stupid and just recognizes that too much
imagination leads to so much instability
on top of the insane instability caused
by the technology that they're just
backing off from it because that it is a
good thing for things to be a little
stable oh no it's definitely a good
things a good thing for things to be a
little stable in fact it's oh I'm sorry
yeah I'm falling down on the job here
yeah the question was essentially what
if what if people are simply so afraid
of the instability that the that the
presence of the imagination might
conceivably cause that they back away
from sort of my clarion call to to
activity out of anxiety or fear of what
might be required of them then he said
isn't it good to have stability in the
culture and it's definitely good I mean
there has there needs to be one of my
favorite books is Paul Wreckers ideology
in Utopia and he makes a very cogent
argument in that book about the
relationship and the necessity of
ideology which
in a neutral sense provides a kind of
continuity and cultural stability and
the function of utopia which is
basically to create a distance from the
culture as a place we're not we don't
necessarily live but from which we can
look at what we have
so the imagination and in this utopic
sense is about creating that distance
and in the present in our culture you
know the problem is one of balance as
Steven says you know so the question is
one of how do we create again that
distance the way I've been describing it
is and it's a little metaphor that Vic
and Stein came up with and he said
imagine a fly in a bottle that wants to
know what the bottle looks like well in
order the bottle is culture right so in
order for that flight to know what the
bottle looks like it has to create
imagine an imaginary space outside of
the bottle in order to begin to think
about what kind of bottle that's in and
whether it might like to be in a
different kind of bottle for example our
problem at present isn't that we don't
want to know what the bottle looks like
although we don't seem to want to know
what the bottle looks like but that we
don't know that we're in a bottle at all
so what I'm saying is that there's not a
healthy kind of balance between this
kind of stability that a necessary
ideology provides for continuity so that
we can all feel that we share the same
world right intersubjectivity are we in
the bottle well maybe it's not one ball
maybe it's a series of connected bottles
but them but to me it's a matter of
creating that utopic space again I think
that the utopic function is impoverished
so the culture is out of balance at this
point there's not enough distance there
aren't enough spots outside of the
culture from which we can look at it and
both critique it and imagine and make
propositions the imagination has its
most important function is propositional
I mean it's going to have a hundred bad
ideas before it has a good one but it's
always proposing things and therefore it
keeps the it keeps the culture fluid you
know it keeps it from becoming a kind of
authoritarian state
yes ma'am very interesting that you use
the word penetration now what what is
happening that make this penetration
very effective what is happening in
effective ineffective what what is
happening that makes the social
penetration or the desire for the
imagination to have social penetration
what's prohibiting that what's making it
ineffective well I think that's what you
know I'm talking about with the enemies
of the imagination they are managing
forces so we're being very well managed
defeat those well it's around us all the
time and I think a lot of us do react to
it I mean when people are polled about
you know what they think about the role
of American corporations in our life
world they say it's too powerful I mean
by overwhelming majority of people think
it's too powerful I mean it you don't
have to be marks to know that having
Walmart as the largest employer in the
country is not a good thing you don't
have to be marks to figure out that if
if if this keeps going the only place
you're gonna have to buy anything is
gonna be at a Sam's Club you know and
who cares what you call your police
state if it's a police state you call it
Sam's Club is fine for me you know the
the Sam's Club police state so you know
so it's not like we're not really aware
I think we are aware the the question is
how how disturbed are we at this point
and you know how troubled are we how
irritated are we I think a lot of people
are irritated and you know in this
culture as divided as it is it's it's
gonna be a real struggle the question is
what formed is that that does that
struggle take
people seem to react to things they can
feel it but they abandon it they are at
that point very passive about really you
know penetrating so to speak well you
know I do one more comment on this so
the question is why are people passive
in the face of these things and I I
don't think it's unreasonable for people
to have a certain level of anxiety you
know once once you start acknowledging
certain things and you start
acknowledging that it's necessary to
change them which i think is important
and necessary at the same time you it is
you know you you have to wonder what it
will require of you you know what am I
going to have to risk to take part in
this and that's a frightening thought
it's very you know if someone is nervous
about that I don't blame them I mean it
but it's part of the of the problem
we're faced with yes sir I I haven't
read your book so I've to apologize I'm
just gonna go even saying you're
forgiven but thank you but can make up
for it alright I'll see what I can do
I'll see what I can do you seem to be
describing this this conflict with
India's capital C capitalism and this
capital I imagination which which I in
my experience that the working world
just I don't perceive it that way I mean
even if I were to you know to defend
even even Walmart there's some
brilliantly imaginative things they do
like two-thirds of what they sell they
you buy it before they even pay for it I
mean there's there's brilliant stuff and
and for any of us right we don't the
when maybe I just referred this to much
room I'm thinking you're saying
something other than what you're saying
but no one is forcing any of us to shop
at Walmart there's thousands of stores
particularly here right no come on
who forced you is there is a I'm gonna
gun the Walmart gun after wait wait
when this is done I'm gonna escort you
from this place cuz I fear for your
safety
under my wing all right all right but
just a sec III want to respond I do sort
of make the kind of black-and-white
drama in the introduction there that and
in a way that I think the rest of the
book mellows a bit and I in fact look
very care I mean to two things really
carry the book I'm being a little black
and white and polemical in the
introduction okay but I wanted to
connect it to all kinds of of
antagonisms within the culture things
that we're familiar with but I do two
things in in the book I think one of
them the most serious thing that I do is
connected with my with my training as a
literary critic I read texts and one of
the texts that I've read is you will be
interested I think in looking at that
chapter when you buy the book a little
later until you have your opportunity to
read it is Richard the book by Richard
Florida called the new a creative
economy in which he talks about you know
the fact that you know this is really a
great time to be you know in capitalism
because it's such a creative world and
really the workers own the means of
productions now because they're the
creative people that drive the engine
okay I look at that argument and I look
at his book in great detail and I think
I I answer something like the question
that you have even though you know I
know nothing about Walmart because I've
never set foot in one time for probably
a couple more questions yes but you made
a remark on Ben skis program yesterday
on kface and I'd like you to amplify if
you would something about somebody who
gets a grant or gets some sort of
scholarship to investigate something and
part of it is always handing back to the
person asking you to investigate that
they're part of the problem then I get
that writer you were not saying that at
all
it's not ringing a bell so pass yes sir
in the back well it seems to me that one
of your claims is that the imagination
is propositional and that you're trying
to kind of bring back a call to arms for
the imagination and yet at the same time
what your book is doing is it's almost
kind of destructive more and I'm
wondering it's it seems like it's kind
of taking down Terry Gross or Saving
Private Ryan which I'm no you know fan
of necessarily but instead of being
destructive it seems like it instead of
being propositional it's kind of falling
into this sense of the sixties as you
know the time that was was so great and
as premier literates that idea
completely because a lot of people have
sort of mistaken what I'm saying for
kind of I'm sorry the question had to do
first it was a comment in the comment
was I you talked about the imagination
as a propositional and creative thing
but what you're doing basically it
sounds like in your book is tearing
things down and isn't what you're doing
basically a form of nostalgia for the
60s and what a great time that was blah
blah blah did my only interest in the
60s which I think you know I we can all
say now I had you know good and bad
things but it was basically didn't
didn't didn't have the legs that we
needed it to have the only thing I want
to preserve from that I don't want to go
back to anything and we won't even talk
about the fact that I have every piece
of hippy vinyl that was ever made you
know we're not gonna go there the only
thing I want to preserve from the from
the 60s is this fiction that I think I
grew up into which was the following the
world is open to my participation the
future is open to possibility the world
can be other than it is and I think that
you know if you ask people now and I
think this is a fundamental question for
the book who owns the future
it wouldn't be we it would be Walmart or
the corporations or somebody other than
ourselves we don't feel like we have
much of
role in the creation of our own future
and it seems to me a fundamental aspect
of what it means to be a human being to
have the right to create your own world
humans have the right to create the
human world and that's I don't think you
know corporations have more freedom than
any individual does at present or any
group of individuals as for the thing
about my being merely destructive in
this world you know I mean I'm enough of
a Marxist and certainly enough of a
young of a young Marxist not about
myself but the young Marx that sort of
the humanist Marx to say that it's
important to make a ruthless critique of
everything and in many ways I think what
I tried to do is participate in that
tradition so part of part of the
creative process is critical and in this
last two chapters of the book I try to
be not about a ruthless critique or
malevolent irony I try also to be
talking about things like my notion of
the sublime or how the arts can again
where the imagination can't again work
for us one more question yes sir George
Bush
Fila then a lot of us have that this is
1932 in Germany you think there's time
before this all comes down another use
the question is given given the the
conclusions of finality and
inevitability that we get from people
like Margaret Thatcher and Ronald Reagan
and George Bush and the question is is
there time remaining to us before this
all comes down around our ears aren't we
really living in Germany in something
like Germany in 1932 and you know it's
even worse than that frankly because you
know they didn't have the nuclear
weapons at that time they didn't have
the capacity for they didn't have
certain kind of environmental dangers
that we have now so you know if you read
Helen Helen Caldicott work on the new
the new nuclear danger for example I
mean I couldn't sleep for weeks after
reading that book so you know it is a
very much a kind of a hair-trigger world
but what I would say what I would say
you know especially in the absence of
any clear political alternative at this
point is that Adorno puts it this way in
the beginning of his book minimum Oralia
he says life does not live well you know
if we're gonna go down I'm gonna go down
alive so you know what I say people say
what should I do and I say be alive you
know because when you're alive you you
kind of have an aura I mean people who
are really alive having our and that's
attractive to other people and that
that's a kind of thing that can that can
organize become social and that's the
critical thing it's sort of like I mean
most of us I think our favorite form of
Buddhism is Mahayana because in the
Mahayana system the Bodhisattva doesn't
jettison often to Nirvana it sticks
around out of compassion for the four
people that are still in the world of
suffering and change and so you know
what I want to do is be alive in this
world with others and encourage them to
the same thing and that that's sort of
the hope that any artist I think is
always projecting into his or her world
and that's what I try to do as an artist
and I hope I'm trying to do as a thinker
and I'm gonna have to call it quits
there and I'm very happy to talk to
people afterwards but we need to get
closure on this if for no other reason
than c-span has but I'm really happy to
stick around and talk Thank You Curtis
Wyatt